breaking news cate blanchett joins  marvel studios through her ragnarok as  the mysterious and powerful new villain  hella jeff goldblum joins the cast as  the eccentric grandmaster Tessa Thompson  will bring the classic hero Valkyrie to  life on the big screen and Karl Urban  will add his mic to the fray as scourge  rounding out the cast is Mark Ruffalo  reprising his role as Bruce Banner aka  the Hulk  Thor's new cast members join returning  stars Chris Hemsworth as the title  character Tom Hiddleston as the  mischievious Loki Idris Elba as the  Asgardian sentry Heimdall and Sir  Anthony Hopkins again portraying Odin  ruler of Asgard Marvel's Thor Ragnarok  is the third installment for Marvel's  popular newer superhero and is directed  by oscar-nominated filmmaker Taika  Waititi what do you guys think of the  big news tell us down below true  believers I'm Lorraine Cink for Marvel  your universe